hope it is the only thing
stronger than fear
hey tributes it looks like our
long-awaited return to pan am is about
to become a reality
that's right there's a hunger games
prequel in the works and we might
already know the ending
lionsgate has confirmed their plans to
turn the bout of song birds and snakes
into a movie
that means more games more district 12
and the return of one of the franchise's
most complicated characters
the ballad of songbirds and snakes will
take place 64 years before the first
hunger games movie
author suzanne collins recently read an
excerpt from the first chapter of the
book which follows 18 year old cory
elaina snow as he prepares for the
reaping
of course this is the same snow that
becomes a tyrannical president
by the time katniss everdeen gets around
to participating in the games but the
new prequel will paint snow in a
different light
as a down on his luck misunderstood
citizen of pan
am who suddenly gets chosen to mentor a
district 12 tribute for the 10th annual
hunger games
we can't imagine snow being a good or
thoughtful leader to a young girl like
hamich was to katniss
you can do this but since this is before
his days as president
we'll uh try to give him the benefit of
the doubt but snow
isn't a district 12 citizen or even a
competitor in the games
he was born into a fairly wealthy family
in the capital but the snows eventually
fell on hard times and had to resort to
the black market to keep themselves
clothed and fed
at the time of the prequel snow was one
of the top performing students at the
capitals academy
being chosen as a mentor is a great
honor but being chosen as a mentor for
one of the most disappointing districts
is completely different
snow ends up developing a pretty big
hatred for district 12 by the time
katniss comes around
following the actions of a few radicals
in the quarter quail
which could be explained by how he was
forced to work with the district when he
was only 18.
we already know a few things about the
10th hunger games thanks to some
references made in the original trilogy
all of this information already appears
in the books but we'll warn you there
are a few spoilers ahead if you want to
go into the prequel blind
first we know that district 2 tribute
griffin naismith ends up winning the
10th edition of the games
we can expect to see him be even worse
than some of the most memorable violent
tributes like cato and clove
but of course griffin winning means that
snow's district 12 tribute doesn't
will losing his tribute affects knows
mental health will this be what sent him
down a cruel path towards the presidency
this brings us to another piece of
knowledge about the 10th games
there is a very good chance they were
rigged it's no secret that the capital
has picked favorites over the years
there should be 74 victors in total but
there's actually 88
officially listed this means that some
of the games were definitely
tampered with or the records of those
games were rewritten and that's why
collins is choosing to focus on
this tournament it could be the start of
snow's bitterness his tribute could have
been the one closest to winning the
games before the game maker picked a
favorite
and ruined everything and speaking of
game makers we know that seneca crane
the maker of the 74th games
is definitely not in this one instead
the 10th hunger games was controlled by
lucas castor the second ever game maker
who started his career during the 6th
annual hunger games
by the time we get to see him in the
prequel he'll have already had four
years of preparing
fatal arena challenges under his belt
caster's plans for the 10th hunger games
are going to be a nightmare for the
tributes
but maybe we'll get to see how seneca
was inspired by the historic game maker
that's it that's excellent
so why did suzanne collins decide to
pick the villain as the focus of her new
novel
with the books she wants to explore the
state of nature
who we are and what we perceive is
required for our survival
she also points out that after these
dark days reflect how pan am struggled
back to its feet
and how she wanted her characters to
grapple with these questions and thereby
define their views of humanity
we can definitely expect to be
questioning our own thoughts and
feelings
as we try to root for a character who
will one day become one of pan
am's most evil and oppressive leaders
so which characters can we expect to see
make a return in the new movie
well of course there's a young president
snow who will be following for most of
the story
but there's another character that's
confirmed to appear her name is tigress
barton and she's actually snow's cousin
which collins revealed in the very first
few pages of the new novel
tigress appeared in mockingjay as a
clothing shop owner who helps katniss
and peta
she's one of the most physically
modified people in the entire capital
which makes her a pretty big outsider
but the prequel will likely depict her
before
all of those crazy modifications maybe
most of the other hunger games
characters weren't even alive for the
10th hunger games
snow was 82 by the time katniss
participated in the games but there is
one former tribute who might make an
appearance
mags is a district 4 tribute who appears
in catching fire
to play in the games alongside finnick
when she competed in the hunger games
she was only 16 and 1. she's actually a
wonderful lady and while most of the
movie's characters are going to be fresh
faces
we will get to see many of our favorite
pan am settings come to life again
like district 12 the capitol and the
arena and we can't wait to see what the
parade of tributes has in store for us
this time
but the big question is is the hunger
games really the hunger games
without katniss it's kind of like when
you watch fantastic beasts and just
can't help missing harry potter
if the wizarding world is missing a
piece without daniel radcliffe involved
can the hunger games prequel draw an
audience without j-law let us know what
you think in the comments
francis lawrence who directed catching
fire and both parts of mockingjay
will be returning to the director's
chair for the prequel
took it easy he'll be joined by suzanne
collins who is executive producing and
adapting the screenplay
along with co-screenwriter michael arndt
who also worked on the previous hunger
games films
nina jacobson and brad simpson will also
return as producers
but we know what you're really wondering
about is the cast there's a chance that
donald sutherland and eugenie bonduran
who played snow and tigris in the
original trilogy will make cameos as
their characters if the movie contains a
little flash forward
they're so fascinating it's fascinating
to see so far there's no official
casting news for the flick but fans have
been going crazy fan casting a young
president snow
our one fan favorite is adam driver who
could bring his skills as star wars
anti-hero kylo ren to the world of pan
am
a blonde haired atom driver huh that
would definitely look the part and can
make us sympathize a little with the
hard-to-love future president
will poulter is another popular pick and
he actually has experience with young
adult movie adaptations from starring in
the maze runner movies
stranger things star daiquiri montgomery
is another great choice
and we all know that he's great at
playing a villain you can root for but
let us know in the comment section down
below
who you would cast to play snow in the
prequel the prequel novel
might end up being a one and done kind
of deal but there's definitely a long
future ahead for the hunger games
franchise
lionsgate was already on top of this
book by the time colin started writing
it and are committed to keeping future
hunger games projects at lionsgate which
is no surprise considering it's one of
their biggest moneymakers
they've also licensed the rights to the
property for future use at amusement
parks and live shows which means
we might get to visit pan am in person
one day which
sounds both terrifying and kind of
amazing for now
we're gonna focus on the prequel movie
and hope that the odds for even more
hunger games content
are ever in our favor happy hunger games
you won't have to wait long to find out
what happened during the 10th annual
hunger games
the novel will be released on may 19th
but it'll probably be a couple of years
before the hunger games finally returns
to theaters
are you looking forward to getting to
know snow better or would you rather
focus
on another character let us know your
thoughts in the comments
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
you